E aí
Olá pessoal boa noite né Já estamos de
noite meu nome é Ana Carla Sou psicóloga
e eu trabalho com inclusão educacional
nesses poucos segundos que se passaram
desde que eu subi aqui deu problema no
microfone e me apresentei você já
começaram tirar algumas conclusões sobre
mim a partir da minha sexualidade então
por exemplo vocês perceberam que eu me
identifique no canto mulher né ele era
uma olhada deve ser mulher então vocês
imaginaram que provavelmente dentro
dessa causa dessa calça que existe uma
página e que aqui dentro Eu tenho útero
e se eu te perguntasse para você está
verde de manhã ela parece que tem um
parceiro deve ter um companheiro alguma
coisa assim isso aconteça aconteceu
comigo agora isso aconteceu com todo
mundo que passou por aqui hoje isso
acontece com vocês todos os dias nesses
contatos superficiais que a gente vai
estabelecendo com as pessoas a gente vai
tirando conclusões vai ter ideias a
partir da sexualidade dessas oque
acontece com todo mundo só que são
interr e para problemas muito grande
porque na nossa sociedade a Sexualidade
elas são valorados de forma desigual tá
vou dar um exemplo se eu Contasse para
vocês que na verdade eu sou transexual
essa página que vocês imaginam não
existe eu tenho um pênis dentro da minha
calça
E aí
vai mudar Dinha né E se eu comprar que
eu sou lésbica
E aí os conceitos mudar um pouquinho
mais esse eu conta que eu fui mãe
adolescente eu tive um filho com 14 anos
E se eu contar que eu tenho HIV Eyes
o seu conta ainda que eu não tenho o
mínimo interesse em ter um
relacionamento afetivo-sexual com
ninguém
não quero não tenho a mínima vontade que
eu tô querendo dizer para vocês é
existem sexualidades na nossa sociedade
que são marginalizados e privadas de
direito e a gente vai identificando E
cria uma ideia sobre essas essas
sexualidade a Sexualidade que eu quero
conversar um pouquinho com vocês hoje é
a Sexualidade das pessoas com
deficiência ela é uma sexualidade mais
realizada é uma sexualidade privada de
muitos direitos e dentro desse Campo
amplo de estudo que a Sexualidade de
pessoas com deficiência a gente tá
estudando a Sexualidade de pessoas com
autismo
eu vou dar só um Panorama bem Geral do
que ela autismo e a gente já volta para
sexualidade que eu sei que vocês
gostaram pelo jeito o autismo ele é um
jeito de ser outra o transtorno do
espectro autista ele é muito múltiplo as
pessoas são obviamente muito diferentes
ao singulares mas desisti as
características em comum por exemplo as
pessoas com autismo costumam ter
dificuldades de comunicação em níveis
diferentes você encontra pessoas com
autismo que falam então discurso super
de retinha assim super bem elaborado tem
pessoas que nunca chegam a desenvolver a
oralidade a dificuldade de interação
social é uma marca então dificuldade de
se colocar no lugar do outro dificuldade
de entender como é que as relações
sociais funcionam como é que as regras
sociais funcionam
expressão facial é muitas vezes não é
que essa expressão pastel tá querendo me
dizer que eu não tô entendendo isso é
muito comum e os interesses muito
repetitivos que ele falar do mesmo
assunto por muito tempo um período longo
de tempo as movimentos repetitivos
atividades repetitivas
hipersensibilidade algumas temos assim o
que quiser entender um pouquinho mais
sobre o assunto referência não nos falta
mas eu indico que vocês Leiam materiais
escritos pelas próprias pessoas com
autismo eu tenho uma ideia de como é o
que que é ser artista o que que é o
erotismo Como adicionar um aspecto as
pessoas são muito diferentes entre si
essas dificuldades que eu falei para
vocês que existem né nas vidas das
pessoas com autismo é muito frequente
que ela se generalizem para sexualidade
as pessoas pensam ser em Então meu filho
tem autista a Sexualidade dele não vai
existir ou meu filho tem autismo a
Sexualidade dele vai ser deficitária
isso não é necessariamente verdade a
gente já toma isso de antemão o que que
isso gera uma invisibilidade dessa
sexualidade
Atalaia consequência hoje as pessoas com
autismo elas compõem um grande grupo de
vulnerabilidade com relação ao abuso e
violência sexual
e vamos supor que você viu em si uma
situação de abuso como é que você vai
recortar ela se você não sabe nem nome
as partes do seu corpo se você não sabe
falar sobre o funcionamento de uma
relação sexual
outra coisa que contribui para essa
invisibilidade essa posição de
infantilização que a gente põe muitas
vezes a pessoa com autismo então é da lá
com 30 anos ainda é tratada como um bebê
pela família não tem direito a voz não
tem direito à privacidade não tem
direito as escolhas da própria roupa de
interações sociais e aí por outro lado
Existe alguma outra posição que a gente
ouve muito nas escolas e que é o
seguinte é Aí ó eles passam masturbando
na frente de todo mundo sempre que ela
sexualidade
descontrolada o que a gente faz então
esse exemplo da masturbação ele é muito
bom para a gente ter uma noção de como
foi a nossa educação sexual e de como a
educação sexual dessas pessoas vão
pensar junto aqui ó como a gente
aprendeu sobre Ah então não precisa
falar só pensa como é que a gente
aprendeu sobre motivação
a atriz segundos pra vocês é
e
é muito frequente que a gente aprenda
sobre masturbação
ouvindo os nossos coleguinhas falar uma
história aqui outra história ali os
parentes começam a fazer umas piadas
conforme a gente vai entrar na puberdade
a gente vê na televisão a gente Aquela
sessãozinha da revista de perguntas e
respostas E assim a nossa sexualidade
vai se desenvolvendo e a gente vai
aprender sobre o mundo a masturbação foi
um exemplo mas é assim que a gente
aprende sobre grande parte das coisas
acerca da nossa sexualidade que eu tô
querendo dizer para vocês É Nós
aprendemos sobre sexualidade ao longo da
nossa vida de uma maneira muito Sutil de
uma maneira muito nas Entrelinhas nos
melindres sociais só que esse jeito de
ensinar sobre sexualidade não serve para
pessoa com autismo na verdade ela é bem
complicada para todas as pessoas mas com
essas dificuldades da pessoa com autismo
isso fica ainda mais grave e o que que a
gente tem como resgatar os dados da
literatura indicam por exemplo que a
pessoa com autismo ela sofre é grandes
índices de depressão de ansiedade
angústias muito fortes Especialmente na
época da adolescência
relacionadas a esse desenvolvimento da
sexualidade deficitário no grandes
números de abuso de violência sexual
relacionada a essa população
os seus direitos que são negadas porque
os nossos direitos sexuais tem que ser
garantidos independente das nossas
condições de vida é é
muito triste que em plena 2016 gente mas
também 2016 penso o quanto de coisa que
a gente conquistou na humanidade até
agora a gente chegou em um Smart a gente
tem roubou a gente tem que tecnologia
que só que a gente está em 2016 eu venho
aqui falar para vocês não pede um pedex
que a gente tem que respeitar
sexualidade do outro
pensa no quanto você maluco mas também
2016 e o futuro improvável é que nós
temos que O que foi mais do outro
Independente de como ou tem ele seja no
caso da pessoa com autismo que tá
extremamente vulnerável por isso daí Que
assunto no mestrado para meu orientador
aqui também trabalha com sexualidade de
ciência e aí Nós criamos uma proposta a
nossa proposta de trabalho ela ela anda
em dois movimentos ao mesmo tempo o
primeiro movimento é o trabalho com a
pessoa com autismo que que é esse
movimento psicoterapia para aprender a
desenvolver habilidades social
fonoterapia para desenvolver linguagem
terapia ocupacional para desenvolver as
questões sensoriais
neuropsicomotoras
acesso a médico há remédio Então vai ser
o primeiro movimento com uma pessoa com
autismo é fácil não é fácil porque como
a gente já comentou hoje o nosso sistema
de saúde o nosso sistema de educação ele
é muito despreparado nesse sentido a
nossa luta para defender a vivência da
sexualidade da pessoa com autismo ela
entrelaçada com outras lutas a luta
pelas é pública de qualidade e pela
educação pública de qualidade ou seja
profissionais que estejam preparados
para atender essas pessoas
2016 voltando para nossa realidade ainda
é um futuro improvável falar que a gente
tem saúde e educação pública de
qualidade então percebe como estava
conversando sobre isso hoje mais cedo
percebe como que todas as nossas lutas
se entrelaçam eu tô falando aqui de
inclusão eu tô falando de sexualidade e
eu tô falando que a gente precisa de
saúde e de educação pública de qualidade
para promover esse nosso primeiro
movimento
o nosso segundo movimento que a gente
vem por aqui é um movimento de mudança
social é o movimento de mudanças macro
em primeiro lugar a gente tem que mudar
nossas ideias sobre a Sexualidade das
pessoas com deficiência que a gente acha
que elas não existem essa é a nossa
primeira mudança em segundo lugar a
gente tem que mudar a maneira como os
profissionais conversam não sei se
alguém que é profissional da educação ou
da Saúde nós existe são ilhas de
tratamento as pessoas não se conversa
então pera aí vamos pensar que nós somos
um adolescente com autismo e a gente tem
uma dúvida aí a gente vai lá perguntar
para nossa mãe ô mãe como é que é que
funciona por exemplo Como é que os bebês
vêm ao mundo pergunta clássica Como é
que os bebês não não dá esse uma
responde uma coisa você ganha aí você
vai não só psicólogo pergunta você se
cola Viu como é que os bebês é o mundo
daí a gente eu já ouvi Cada história
muito engraçada sobre isso tem que falar
vem do ovo as mães são muito criativas
né as mães e os profissionais são muito
criativo Nessa fala e fica não responde
uma coisa essa sexualidade ela vai ser
completamente estava nada ela não vai
saber muito bem Como é que o mundo
funciona então a gente tem que se
conversar e agora eu vou falar o mais
importante de tudo do nosso trabalho da
nossa proposta que é um trabalho com a
família gente a família da pessoa com
deficiência a família da pessoa com
autismo é quem tá junto é quem sofre é
quem luta todo dia tá Às vezes a pessoa
família da pessoa com autismo ela não
recebe nem apoio na hora do diagnóstico
Então você leva seu filho no médico e
ele fala que seu filho é autista e você
vai embora porque ele barulho na cabeça
Dependendo de qual sua vulnerabilidade
social em qual é o seu acesso você vai
ficar com esse barulho na cabeça por
anos na nossa pesquisa a gente
perguntava em primeiro lugar como é que
foi o diagnóstico seu filho e elas
falaram assim ah eu sei que é autismo
mas não sei muito bem o que que é isso e
o filho lá com vinte anos se passaram 20
anos com essa família ali se remoendo o
que que é isso é autismo Então imagina
você família não tem apoio psicológico
não tem acolhimento não tem escuta Nem
para falar sobre o diagnóstico imagina
sobre a Sexualidade nessas pessoas
essas sexualidade que muitas vezes ela
entremeada por sofrimento por
dificuldade por ansiedade
bom então a gente precisa desses dois
movimentos ao mesmo tempo Pois é quando
eu tô falando que a gente quer promover
educação sexual das pessoas com autismo
e das pessoas em geral quando todos
sabem que é o objetivo também eu não tô
falando que eu que eu tô psicólogo eu
chegar lá vou pegar o adolescente lá vem
aqui que eu vou te ensinar tudo fica
tranquilo vai dar tudo certo eu não
posso fazer isso porque a Sexualidade
desenvolveu ao longo da nossa vida a
gente aprende ao longo da nossa vida
então esse trabalho que eu tô propondo
que eu proponho ele é macro ele é muito
grande o que não significa que ele é
impossível Nós temos tudo que a gente
precisa vem comigo a gente tem
profissionais a fim de fazer familiares
a fim de fazer nós ao longo da nossa
trajetória de humanidade desenvolvemos
muitos materiais sobre educação sexual
para todas as idades com todos os
objetivos possíveis e imagináveis e nós
temos muito conhecimento teórico de como
ensinar pessoas com autismo a gente tem
muita coisa produzida diversas
estratégias para os mais as
características das pessoas com autismo
só que essas Onde fica esse conhecimento
da Universidade nos livros nos serviços
particulares de saúde de educação e
serviço não está chegando aqui realmente
interessa que é a população em geral
Então nossa luta nesse sentido é mapa e
é por isso que eu fico tão feliz de
poder falar sobre esse assunto não pede
eu não sei se vocês perceberam mas no
Ted Unesp Bauru a inclusão veio para
ficar isso minha filha isso é incrível é
as pessoas com deficiência elas estão
tomando os lugares de fala e é com isso
que eu gostaria de terminar é conta do
meu projeto Eu sou uma mulher simples eu
sou branca classe média eu tenho ensino
superior e eu
sou hétero eu tô falando eu sou
neurotypical seja não tem autismo e eu
tô falando sobre experiências que Gente
eu nunca vou saber como são eu nunca vou
saber como é ter autismo Então por mais
há nada que eu seja por mais que o meu
projeto seja bom tem a qualidade e eu
sei que vai dar certo que a gente tem
vontade de fazer
o museu tempo aqui são as pessoas com
autismo Então o que eu realmente estéreo
com o meu trabalho que eu espero do
trabalho de vocês é de quem tiver
ouvindo é que a nossa luta seja para as
próximas pessoas da botar esse microfone
aqui e vim falar sobre a Sexualidade
sejam as pessoas com autismo E aí até lá
a gente não para a gente continua
trabalhando essa verdadeiro propósito da
inclusão
obrigado a